foreign
I feel alone in this empty house it's a
little complicated
but I know we about to go off now
Saturday night feeling my vibe I'm a
good challenge like I always do kicking
it back copy fast about to go out like I
am used to dancing with the boys and the
girls girls yeah doing what we do in the
world we are
as you know that we are one thousand
percent we do it our way don't care what
they say cause you know that we are one
thousand
we keep it up we keep it at one thousand
you best believe that keep it up we keep
it at one thousand after all is said and
done we still got us we got love we're
one a toast to us the thousandth one
we gonna keep this up because we are one
thousand percent we do it our way don't
care what they say cause you know that
we are one thousand
we keep it air we keep it one thousand
you best believe it we keep it in one
thousand
happy one thousand y'all love you y'all
good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Thursday but
most importantly happy 1
000 episode of the toast formerly known
as the morning toast nevertheless here
we are hey Jax how you turn I'm darn
good ready to celebrate 1000
we keeping it we keeping it one thousand
you best believe it you best believe it
literally I can't believe it me neither
I hope you guys enjoyed you know that
special performance we put together for
you it took a lot of work yeah but it
was so worth it we needed something
really special to commemorate
this Milestone I feel like if you're not
I feel like most people who aren't
listening are like that's insane a
thousand episodes but I could see some
people being like well you do it every
day do you think right so great I went
to my job a thousand days like good for
you I feel like we just need to really
acknowledge acknowledge the importance
because it's not of course you go to
your job a thousand days but to put out
1 000 podcast episodes isn't insane
level of podcasting and that's not that
doesn't even include patreon
apparently like we've really if you
think about it nice and deep we've
reached a thousand a long time ago after
you know patreon going on other people's
podcasts but the toast here a thousand
episodes I feel so proud of us I love
the toast love I am curious I think I
was having we were having this
conversation do you think there's a
person out there who has listened to
every single episode of the toast
I feel like yeah I feel like yes in
theory but maybe no you know because
think about all the people who have been
with us like really since day one it's
not like that many people who have been
here from the beginning but even that
those people like who have been here
from day one like something came up they
have a limited episode there was a guest
about right right right and even you and
I were saying like I don't think either
of us have listened to every single
episode because while we've been here
for 95 of them you know when I was on
the road and you were maternally like I
wasn't watching every single one I
wasn't but neither were you on when I
was on maternity leave I definitely like
missed a couple of yours and when I used
to host without you and you would go on
tour I know you weren't watching this I
was busy you were busy so
I don't know if there's anyone out there
who's watched all 1000 if you have
sure there's no way to prove it but just
like if you really believe that you have
show yourself yeah let us know it's nice
to know like we're not speaking in to
avoid no well we're not speaking them to
avoid even if someone didn't tune in
every 1 000 days right because people
are tuning in so let's take a look back
in order to look ahead right
what what are you feeling in this moment
Jax I'm feeling proud I'm feeling like
we've reached a level of podcasting
that's like elite elite you know because
not only do we have a top podcast which
a lot of people do especially when you
launch your podcast you're probably in
the top if you're an existing influencer
or celebrity or notable person but it's
like we are tops and we've been doing it
for so long and we're tops even after a
thousand episodes like call me when your
tops after a thousand episodes when
people get to know you a thousand times
do they still like you I would agree I'm
feeling an enormous sense of Pride also
you know a little condescension like
we're better than all the others like
where how many episodes Have You Done
300 oh that's cute I remember when we
hit 300 we were so young it was like 12
years ago it does also make you feel
like a little old you know just a little
but more not only more established the
older you get in this industry and
you're still having success like that to
me is so impressive I agree impressive
than a young person or a novice having
success right it's hard to stay well
everything is exciting at first and
everyone can churn out a couple podcasts
everyone has something to say yeah but
you have something to say 1 000 times
every day and to unpard in yourself one
thousand times so it's Pride it's
definitely a little holier than now it's
also a little anxiousness about you know
the tape holding together these balloons
I'm not gonna lie these balloons are not
you know welded to the wall no they are
being held together by you know duct
tape and a prayer it is a DIY moment for
tardy and I it was a DIY moment for
tardy and I yes and that's pretty much a
summation of what I'm feeling yeah and I
say that these balloons represent this
show Hanging On by a threat not only in
the 1000th of their nature but they're
so beautiful and they add so much color
but you know at any moment you never
know what they're gonna do they could
Twist and Turn it's so true like this
set of balloons is kind of a
personification of our brand yeah not
that they would like Snap and disappear
and like we're not going anywhere but
like we just no it's like they look good
but if only you knew what was going on
behind the scenes amazing things amazing
things why are we talking like we're
running like a no no but like I think we
put together actually we're actually
really transparent about like you know
our trials and tribulations like you
know everyone who is here with us
putting together the Florida Studio
members of the days we forgot to put our
microphones on we're pretty transparent
about how like it's low-key difficult to
have a web show yeah also and I feel
like a reason why we wanted to perform a
song this morning I was saying this
yesterday to Claudia it's like so much
of the beginning of this show was really
like us embarrassing ourselves for the
greater good yeah I think our first show
of the toast was extremely embarrassing
oh I don't even think embarrassing is a
strong word if you manage to watch a
whole episode because of the outages
that occurred you know what it was it
wasn't embarrassing it was humiliating
it was
humiliating and then of course we
performed when your first song came out
toast which is one of the most iconic
moments in toast history right but if we
were embarrassed again the speaker
[__] guy yep like we're here we are
like putting ourselves out there making
up a dance and the speaker died and it
was the best moment ever but like we're
a little embarrassing no there's
something about us that is embarrassing
it's I think it's because we're sisters
and like you know we just like have
weird ideas closed down Sunday
very very embarrassing very but like I
would do it all again and like that's
what we're gonna change the thing and I
said to Claude I feel like we've gotten
like a little too cool and we need to go
back to our embarrassing route I
completely agree I'm doing weird sister
[__] I agree and that's what you just
saw earlier today thanks to Ben for you
know getting involved yeah
um I completely agree I completely agree
we are like
constantly just putting ourselves out
there and being embarrassing but I think
that's why people relate to us you know
I hate seeing people who's like
everything is so perfect you know yeah
because it's not no we know it's not
like so stop lying us yeah so we just
needed to go back to our roots and like
obviously we're performers yeah we are
we're extremely musical we love to dance
extremely and this show is encompasses
everything that we love and those are
all the things that we love
you said a pass I couldn't say better if
I wanted to so it was really important
that we did that yeah I felt good I felt
really good and that's how we're gonna
commemorate this special day aside from
balloon I know I kind of love the
balloons they're adding like a cute
accent to our studio I know we need to
just like change out every day I get a
new balloon every day one thousand and
one one thousand and two one thousand
and then we'll never lose count
it's hard to keep count it's hard it is
especially with our new interface right
on the back end like they don't help you
keep count we've been doing it manually
yeah at our old one we used to but
that's just more like podcasts like let
us know if you want it's a separate
patreon it's kind of like an us problem
yeah that we're just like inflicting
onto you but don't worry about it
because we'll like we'll keep track and
we have to keep keeping track because
hopefully Hashem one day two thousand I
only have to get one new balloon so 2000
will be what in like three years how
many years have we been doing the show
oh so five six it'll be in six years
it's like not that many I guess because
there's 365 days in the year we do about
but there's like two two 20 episodes a
year yeah depending on you know you
having children times five and change
yeah
there you go that's us five and change
that's how long we've been doing the
show it's been a pleasure I'd like to
thank everyone who got us here which is
you know me Jackie rice
the unwavering support of our friends
and family we are so blessed yes and
most importantly the unwell well
sometimes wavering we understand the
those who didn't waver yeah the you know
scrupled girlies who listen and boys
excuse me who listen to the show every
day we are so appreciative we love that
you guys just like get us you get our
language you get in on the fun you know
like life isn't that serious you tune
into the toast you're gonna have a good
time you're gonna laugh you're gonna
Giggle and everything's gonna be okay so
thank you to everyone who's ever tuned
into an episode we are so grateful for
you and honestly the toast wouldn't be
the same without the toasters and I
think that's an understatement yeah
we're so grateful to you those who tune
in and keep tuning in yeah we love you
enjoy it even if you like hate watching
you're a fan to spend an hour a day with
us every day you really love us no and I
just I feel good knowing like a thousand
times we've made someone laugh because
at least once an episode we're gonna
make someone laugh so so that's millions
of laughs if my math is correct if we
counted the laughs quad countless it
would be off the charts so we wouldn't
have enough balloons we wouldn't have
enough balloons Party City would be
quaking yeah
these are from Party City yeah yeah
we're like kind of a big big budget
production yeah it was a really premium
experience coming there I love all the
candy they have out I got some Mike
Nikes yeah I kind of like how they've
like individually wrapped you know what
so I went for the individually after I
grabbed a bag to make myself a bag to
unburden myself right of course it was
actually all crap crap it was crap I
think the last time we went to Party
City is when we like were on we were
coming from fat camp like and we had
like a break in the day and we got to go
to Party City to get like some supplies
for the campers you think that's the
last time we've ever been to a party
setting yeah for me in person I believe
that's last time I've been where so I
was so excited oh my God I can get like
piece by piece really like I'm coming so
you're like Kelly Clarkson candy in
months piece by piece but today like as
a grown Discerning woman when I went
it was crap like you know like like the
kind of stuff that's like
like nerds types of the selection was
crap or the quality like was it stale
because the selection was crap I feel
like those pieces like actually sit out
for many months no and there were a lot
of pieces that they weren't they were
like
individually wrapped but not in a way
that felt safe to me yeah individually
rap does open you up to some and like
other people could be like touching it
yeah and it just I had to go for my own
box of Mike and I can back of combos of
course a bag of combos well if I see if
I see a combo I gotta get a combo that's
so funny that I don't have the same um
feeling towards combos but I have the
same feeling towards other things in
general you know what I can't see
without immediately touching and eating
while I'm waiting to pay the mini little
tubes of M M's you know you pop the lid
open something about those they taste
better than regular M M's something
about like sucking it out of that tube
it's delightful I didn't know that was
your predilection I could have picked
one up for you that's my drug of choice
I could have gotten one for you if I had
known I had the hook up at Party City
now you know so put it on the bins I
actually forgot to expense the balloon
what yeah were these balloons expensive
they actually kind of work yeah but this
is a gift from me to the show oh that's
so sweet well I didn't get you anything
you're always getting me something your
presence is a gift no
I did get you something I'm scared I
departure just what you wanted I'm
leaving right after this headed to the
airport good because it's the one you
got literally you're a [__] liar
that's what you wanted you're such a
[__] liar I've been begging to be out
of here by Friday I've been begging you
to stay wenchaholic you said Claudia
used to be out of here by Friday when
she Mick wincherson I've been begging
you to say you [__] liar did you not
say I have to be out of here by Friday
no
really
no someone isn't coming to sleep in my
room so I could have made a mess I could
keep sleeping combinations I could keep
sleeping there the BNB could expand I
could keep sleeping there you can keep
sleeping there hmm it's funny how our
tune changes once I book my flight no
one wants him on the air like [__] come
on
you Charlie gets me out and it's fine
um my time here is up you know no I
actually don't sometimes I feel that way
but I actually don't feel that way like
I feel like you're leaving like in the
middle of something beautiful I know and
you know if I didn't have I kind of have
like you have an event I want to then
tell the truth I have an event on Monday
which like okay Claudia you could stay
till Sunday
um I have to get like a spray tan Nails
I need like three days to decompress
um because I have like a big gig on
Monday for fashion week that I cannot
miss and I cannot be like looking puffy
and like you know gross for so I need to
start my Monday prep tomorrow yeah I
understand that plus it's like if we're
not doing toast episodes if it's just
Saturday and Sunday like you could take
those at home yeah
um and I know you'll be back soon and I
will be up to New York like I think
within the month I'm gonna try yeah
that's my plan this was an unplanned
trip but very necessary one yeah because
of one thousand one thousand and we
didn't even plan it that way no but like
that's just so us Christmas
great things happen when we're together
great things happen when we sing if we
were remote I would have like one zero
on mine and you would have zero I don't
even know how we would have commemorated
and I'm so glad we don't have to even
think about that because we could have
added cool graphics like the 1000s would
be dancing you know the 1000s we're
keeping it we're keeping it one thousand
you best believe it
okay
okay I feel we've acknowledged I feel
we've commemorated and while this is a
special episode we are still here to do
our job like it's not there's something
about this that feels really final but
it's like this is just one episode of
thousands because you know what the
thing about us is The Show Must Go On
The Show Must Go On the terrible stories
must be dissected it wouldn't be like a
quintessential episode if the stories
weren't terrible and they are today's
episode today's stories are like
particularly crappy and it's not even
it's like not sometimes the stories like
there's a lot of landmines out there so
it's like I'm not gonna talk We're not
gonna talk about that story or that
story
um so we kind of you know have to get
creative yeah uh no but today like I
would have talked about anything it's
crap it's crap so if you want to get
into the crap and give give the people
what they want which is crappy-o
you know but we always make the best to
have the crap I said yesterday show them
like hey those stories weren't so bad I
said yesterday the crappier the stories
the better the episode yeah like yeah
it's nice when we have a big Scandal to
dissect and we can really put our
investigative hats on but there's
nothing better than just like endlessly
mocking people and that's what we do
when the stories are so crappy it's true
so without further Ado today's 1000th
episode 1 000
one thousandth
that was Harmony yes it was
but I harmonize you sing the melody
she like won't like Jackie but I am a
heart have we had this conversation on
the podcast where Jackie thinks she's
harmonizing but she's not I don't know
if we've had it on the podcast okay
Jackie thinks she knows how to harmonize
because she's like I can only do it with
Luke Combs like gee I wonder why because
Luke Combs has a really low register so
when girls or Jackie in this case sings
a Luke comb songs she's singing the same
note in higher octave
so she thinks she's harmonizing and
she'll like do it in the car she's like
I just harmonize I'm like no sweetheart
that's not a Harmony it's not a Harmony
it is do you want me to lie to you Margo
said it was a Harmony the [__] does
Margo know about musical theater Margo
knows music no she doesn't she does do
you want to show people no it's like I
Love This Bar
I stumbled gorgeous not a Harmony
if there's like a vocal teacher
listening like tell Jackie how to
harmonize I don't know how to harmonize
it's actually really hard I'm oh Luke
and I like always harmonize on Harmony I
also harmonize little and buy dirt
if you watch my story from yesterday
you'll hear it actually I'm like sitting
in my bathroom and it's like it's crazy
again not a Harmony
you know what is a harmony though this
show it is so harmonious most of the
time yeah sometimes a little acrimonious
I love the acrimony when it's like you
know I get to call you a wench also
raise your hand if you only know the
word acrimonious from Friends
there's like a whole storyline about it
I didn't know that there was a word that
was the opposite of harmonious
it's beautiful turns out it's
acrimonious it's an antonym and I'm so
glad I know that word it's an antonym
and we're such anti-files that we love
antonyms
Trails now without further Ado it is
time for the 1000th time that you know
the past five stories that you need to
know and I'd like to give an extra
special thanks to those who sponsored
our thousandth episode your support you
know keeps the lights on it means a lot
to us thank you for sponsoring today's
episode State Farm thank you to those
who have sponsored along the way to get
us to 1 000
the State Farm personal price plan helps
you create a plan that gives you options
so you get an affordable price and it
comes with a lot of benefits like the
coverage you want a policy that helps
cover what's important to you an
affordable price that's just for you
because after all life is just better
when you can personalize your
experiences we are all about
personalization customization here at
the morning to us whether it's a
playlist that we like Jackie ho ho ho a
personal favorite whether it's comedy
poetry all these things are so personal
and they deserve to be customized just
like your insurance and State Farm they
know that very few things in life are
more personal than Insurance
personalizations means that you have the
power to choose what you want to include
and what you want to leave out it just
feels better that way and why shouldn't
insurance work like that too that's what
the State Farm personal price plan is
all about you can choose to include
options like bundling your home and auto
policies that means you'll get the
coverage you want at an affordable price
just for you in the end you'll have the
policy that gives you what you want what
feels better than that now one of my
favorite things to say and I'm so glad
why State Farm is sponsoring show like a
good neighbor you want to harmonize
State Farm is there
call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan prices may vary by state options
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary again that is call
or go to statefarm.com today to create
your State Farm personal price plan
today's episode is also brought to you
by Sundays Sundays is healthy Sundays is
the air dried dog food made from a short
list of human grade ingredients Sundays
was co-founded by Dr Tory a practicing
veterinarian which I think just brings
peace of mind to dog moms and dads all
around this great nation ourselves
included ourselves so Sundays is
different not and laugh not like other
food they contain 90 Meat 10 vegetables
zero percent synthetic nutrients besides
USDA beef and all natural chicken you
will find digestive AIDS like pumpkin
and ginger also disease fighting
antioxidants so dog parents ourselves
included have reported a noticeable
Health Improvement in their pups
including softer fur for Theo fresher
breath I didn't know what like a main
cause of Theo's breath literally smelled
so bad a few weeks ago
um switching up his food has made an
enormous difference and it turns out
like he wasn't eating real food no USDA
grade you know wasn't eating food that
was like real food real food they a lot
of other dog parents reported better
poops more energy Theo is loving Sundays
he gets so excited at dinner time and
breakfast time
um and it just feels good to know like
we're feeding our dogs I hate to even
call them dogs it's so disrespectful
we're feeding our loved ones we're
feeding our sons the best of the best
you know high quality it's also
affordable Sundays cost 40 less than
other Healthy dog food brands because
Sundays doesn't waste money shipping
Frozen packages instead they spend on
what matters which is sourcing the best
all natural ingredients for your pup
super convenient there's zero prep zero
mess and zero stress we've worked out a
special deal for our dog loving
listeners get 35 off your first order
for Sundays when you go to
sundays4dogs.com toast or just use code
toast at checkout that's
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s.com forward
slash toast upgrade your pup to Sundays
and feel good about the food you feed
your dog thank you turdy welks
our first story a little literary news
it's twofer literally lose literary news
because one Barbra Streisand is
releasing her memoirs called Memoirs of
a Streisand called shifting Streisand
mine's better
um we'll have to leave it to Barbara I
really do think it should be called
shifting Streisand she can't really call
it Memoirs of a Streisand because like
that's just too much of a derivative of
something else and it's like I know she
wants to be her own Woman original and I
think it's like perfect for her career
like the shifting Streisand has she
released the title she has and it's
neither of those um is it good is it a
competitor no it is definitely number
three out of those three it is my name
is Barbara
come again
my name is Barbara and then underneath
that it'll have her name right Barb the
author name Barbra Streisand so it seems
repetitive yeah
so not only that but Leah Michelle has
taken to Tick-Tock to joke about the
whole thing and she said I have 265 days
to learn to read now
I don't know who is responsible but
somebody got Talia Michelle maybe a year
ago less you know I can't really tell
time yeah somebody like around the same
time a funny girl like when she's on
this like press kick somebody gave her a
Stern talking to and said Leah lean in
lean in like you have to start getting
in on the joke the more you're like
defensive about it the more people
actually think you might not be able to
read also this is like a great moment
for you like imagine the content and you
know what she has over delivered she is
it's getting like it's almost getting a
little old but like the fact that she's
now started to lean into it like it's
still acceptable to talk about it
because other people are still talking
about it love this for her I do although
have like questions about her
relationship with Barbra Streisand like
there's no confirmation but I think like
the internet's General assumption is
that like Barbara hates Leah yeah it's
always you know the Tale As Old As Time
of the usurper really
um the young hot thing who everyone's
comparing you to and it's like she's the
new you and that's just [__] rude to
everyone I could and I also like they're
both bona fide Divas yeah so it's not
like Babs it's just
like uplifting everyone all the time
yeah I don't think Babs though like
reached out to Leah or even beanie when
they were cast in the in the Broadway I
don't think Barbara honestly I don't
think she's a woman who supports other
women and that kind of makes me like her
no especially I don't think she's a
woman who supports other women in her
vein yeah yeah yeah women created In Her
Image so like I think she would support
you know a tennis player
100 I think she supports Serena Williams
one thousand percent one thousand
percent we keep in it we're keeping it
one thousand
that was pretty good okay
you sing The Melody yet okay fine no but
together yeah it was gorgeous that's
what we have here we have Harmony
together most of the time most of the
time sometimes there's acrimony and that
is the opposite of Harmony
um another thing about Barbara and Lee
Michelle is like I do believe they've
really only like been in the same room
once together and that was when they did
like a Kennedy Center Honor as a Barbra
Streisand and Lee Michelle and this
picture was taken oh is that where it's
at I don't know it looks like they're at
um sports bar a downtown edgy Club yeah
there's a TV in the background that says
Jody I just well maybe it was like a
post office party when like that Jody
Foster had won oh perhaps but there's
not like a you know a big gallery of
photos of them together like no no
there's this one where Leah looks like a
true fan yeah and so when Leah performed
at that like Barbra Streisand honors
thing um she did amazing and they cut
the camera to Barbara and Barbara just
looks like Beyond annoyed unimpressed I
get it it's Diva Behavior yeah I get it
it's like if there was toast honors and
they had no they had like a bunch of
women trying to be funnier than us yeah
get out of here yeah like doing our bits
like singing 1000. oh my God I would
vomit I would literally so true walk out
of the room that's [__] rude that's
so true
so you have to think about it like no
you're so true I have to put myself in
Barbara's shoes also a good title in my
shoes
I know but like she's got to change the
name of this book it's really bad I will
not be reading this you know one thing
about me I think a lot of people assume
because like I love funny girl
um I'm a Jewish queen and I love to sing
people think like I would like take a
bullet for Barbra Streisand like I
actually wouldn't
I don't really like [__] with her yeah
it's not crazy no it's not like that
crazy you're not predictable that's the
thing about people like if you liked her
you'd be predictable
but you're so unpredictable I like to
keep people on their toes which is why I
decided not to like Barbara Streisand
and why you like some people that people
probably would think that you wouldn't
like that would find really annoying
yeah
Mindy Kaley yeah I was just going to say
that and the country music in general I
don't think people oh yeah but now they
expect it yeah because we bought dirt
it's gonna be really heavy singing
episode as it [__] should be singing
has gotten us twenty one thousand
episodes It's what sets us apart I
wonder where we would be if we didn't
sing
probably at like episode 390 because
we'd have gone down to weekly episodes
because we just like ran out of things
to talk about because we couldn't sing
because we couldn't sing and like Be
Inspired right by ourselves right
ourselves
bad dirt are you gonna read Barbara's
book
no but I think it will be good yeah I
mean she's 80 years old she's had this
insane career movies songs TV Grammy
Tony bus Club yeah another bus so I
think it will be amazing
um amazing story about amazing woman
that I personally won't be reading yeah
but I think it's like there's certainly
an audience for this and I think this is
like huge for them there's a huge
audience the gay community will be first
in line yeah and we need like a strong
celeb Memoir we get a view a year I
think this is going to be great uh the
Publishing House said Barbara is a
living legend a woman who in a career
spanning six decades has excelled in
every area of entertainment and this
engrossing and delightful book will be
eagerly welcomed by her millions of fans
dozens of books have been written about
shy sand but now in my name is Barbara
she tells the story in her own words
there are a few celebrity Memoirs like
highly anticipated Paris is coming out
soon yes Britney's like who knows
paper I feel like it's not coming out
because there's a paper shortage is
there yeah that's what TMZ reported no I
think like we all know why the book is
probably delayed and it's because like
Britney doesn't care and Brittany is
living her life
um
so there are a few good this will be a
good year for celebrity Memoirs that's
exciting stuff I'm ready me too
um ready come and find me I'm not gonna
hack out the sun on my side it's
are you ready for our next story I am
which is some rich people news my
favorite category of news Kylie Jenner
ad is covering the headline starts
construction on a mega mansion three
years after paying 15 million dollars
for a vacant lot near Chris and Chloe's
compounds oh I didn't realize she had a
lot near them yeah because I knew that
she put her house up on the market it's
the one that she like that looks like a
fortress the one yeah that she moved
into it during covid and it's like very
modern she's it's listed for 21.9
million I remember her doing that I was
like oh like where shall she go didn't
she pay way more than that
I remember reporting like 40 or 50 but
then I must be wrong no because like
real estate in Los Angeles is like doing
well it's a good investment yeah yeah
um Los Angeles yeah so new photos aerial
photos of her property in construction
have been obtained exclusively by Daily
Mail showing what appeared to be the
Mansion being built on a hill she's
literally living in a mansion on a hill
though let me show you these pics so
this is the property but wait there's
more this is going to be the Mansion of
course they love that sloping though I
think that's the backyard behind it
and then if you continue this is the
driveway oh it's really big down here
would be like a garage it's like she's
still gonna have to drive to go to Chloe
and Chris's house yeah but I love this
thing that they're doing they're like
kind of creating their own community and
this is all in Hidden Hills I believe oh
I love that they're all like gonna be
easy yeah now you can Envision it do you
think like I feel like Kim's home is her
forever home
yeah she spent so much time on it I
could see Kendall like moving over here
I don't think Kendall's home is like her
forever home and she's still young but
what about Courtney and Travis like they
are I think they're fine right now but
they probably will move because they
need a house together right they don't
have like a family home a blended family
so I think like I mean that's the dream
like being able to buy like in like this
most expensive part of the country five
different Lots all next to each other
that's such a dream such a dream Kylie's
new Hidden Hills property is located in
between properties owned by her mom and
her sister Chloe and then Kim and
Courtney live nearby yeah they all live
in in like the same area but not it
sounds like the three of them are on the
same cul-de-sac yeah that's like so like
that's something I'm extremely jealous
of extremely jealous and I feel like
Chloe and Chris have like loved now
living next to each other once their
homes were finally done and that
architect who like stole their house
um I feel like it's like the best thing
they ever did and now Kylie's there's
like another girly in the cul-de-sac
yeah and it's so fun for all the cousins
like this is that is like a real true
privilege like that I'm jealous of yeah
they're living well we love to see
people like doing like what with their
money like what I would do yeah like if
we had unlimited resources that is
exactly what I would do I would find
like the best neighborhood
purchase like five Lots next to each
other spend time making them our dream
homes forever
and then like raising our kids there
that's like such a dream and what you
would do you'd back okay I would yeah
you found the one you can live without
he got and bring let his knee hit the
ground you do what you love and call it
works thousand percent a thousand
episodes in the turf be careful a
thousand episodes with the turd be
careful do not touch these balloons they
are hanging on my thread okay so Kylie
bought dirt and once again she's showing
she has Country belt yes oh this is so
like a down-home country thing to do but
I think now she will be like in L.A so
she needs someone from Nashville who's
willing to relocate for her I feel like
that's not hard or she could she still
like always wants a farm yeah she should
get a farm yeah
I love this that house looks like sick I
feel like their houses take so long to
build no I feel like they actually don't
like I feel like one day we were
reporting that the contractor like left
Chris and Chloe and then like the next
season they were in their houses yeah
but like they had bought the Lots like
years prior but she bought this lot
three years ago so now we're just like
we have girls who plan I feel like
she'll be in in a year That's so
exciting for her and the kids yeah happy
for her happy for her a little jealous
always it's like 70 happy 30 jealous I
know
um no it's probably like 30 happy 70
jealous no I'm mostly happy I just like
I hope that we get to see a little on
the show and it just like shows us
something she gives us nothing on the
show so I wouldn't you know hold out
hope yeah are you ready for our next
story I am it's by your boyfriend
actually not your boyfriend and you're a
gymnastics teacher Paul Rudd Paul Rudd
says his son used to think he worked at
a movie theater and I never corrected
him an exclusive clip from this
weekend's episode of Sunday today Paul
Rudd sat down with Willie Geist to
discuss whether his kids are aware of
his successful career
Paul said that his son jack 17 and his
daughter Darby 13 have finally put it
all together
that their dad is an actor but things
were very different when they were
little quote when my kids were young I'm
not going to sit my kids down when
they're three and say you know I've got
some DVDs to show you I didn't really
explain what I did then he recalls the
story of when his son was about four or
five and went to see a movie with his
friends at the movie theater well we
were all going and there was a movie
poster that I was on that was in the
lobby so they all just thought that I
worked at the movie theater which I
thought was very cute that's like so
cute and innocent like kids stuff yeah
and then a few years later I think when
he was 15 he finally put it all together
I never corrected him he says teasing
he'd say that he worked at the AMC lows
I too often wonder technically work at
the AMC lows I do often wonder though
like as a child of like an actual famous
person is there like a conversation you
have is it just like you there's not a
moment you just know it your whole life
like
but like you watch movies so like you
know that there are celebrities out
there you know yeah I feel like
eventually it's a conversation that you
have when like they're old enough to
have the awareness of what you're saying
that's so weird depends what level
you're at though I feel like Paul writes
because he doesn't need to be like you
guys we're gonna be mob right by the
paparazzi the Kardashian kids there
there's definitely a course that they
all have to take yeah
I wonder how to navigate that that seems
difficult yeah
yes like yeah it's a conversation you're
gonna have to have like mommy's a big
star right don't be surprised you're
gonna be like we've never seen anything
what is mom talking about I think mommy
is not famous I think she's mentally ill
like no one's following us Mom I'm like
but they are like you can't see you
can't see them really long lenses yeah
they like stay far away but like they
have like the 35 millimeter lens
obsessed with me yum they're like sure
Mommy
yeah and then Daddy's like just go along
with it sure mommy we'll go get you a
Diet Coke yeah sure mommy there's
Paparazzi outside maybe you should put
your sunglasses on
sure Mommy
[Laughter]
oh to dream
maybe maybe
no you know what like I actually
wouldn't want that like I want it now
when I'm like young and thirsty like
when I have kids like obviously burden
no they can't worry about their safety I
think it wears off really quickly you
know once you have kids no and just as a
celebrity like I'm sure the first time
you got Paparazzi you're like oh my God
no I still think like if you're a
celebrity like a thirsty celebrity with
like you know without kids and like
you're young and like you crave that for
a long time
yeah if you're not getting it like
in droves you know yeah that's when it
becomes a burden yeah
anyways Paul Rudd what do we know he
worked at the movie theater and at the
gymnasium
do you still think he was your
gymnastics yes
do you believe me
I believe that that's what you think
he's such a gaslighting wench like it's
one like I I
it's really tough because my memory
often plays tricks on me
but I have such a clear memory of being
a young child
having just seen Clueless
telling my gymnastics teacher he looks
like Josh from Clueless and him giving
me this like knowing wink and smile you
know and then he disappeared like a few
weeks later
because obviously he got so famous he
didn't need to work at gymnastics
anymore yeah
you know Paul red is a Chiefs fan the
Super Bowl this is our last episode
together before the Super Bowl we have
you know tomorrow's episode but like
I'll be back in New York and is there
anything that we want to like say about
it I'm getting pretty excited I'm just
wanting to wish everyone luck I'm
working on my menu oh what's on the on
the menu so I have a really big like
cheese board Cup course which is going
to be so delicious and tasty I'm gonna
make nachos from the Magnolia table
cookbook and like I'll be able to use
kosher beef and that's going to be
Mighty tasting
um
crudite of course I've been like loving
carrots and ranch
ranch I don't give a ranch and then I
think I'm gonna order pizza for the main
course I love that like you know what
just phone it in oh Ben was saying I
should make spinach artichoke dip which
I do have a really good recipe for
Magnolia table
um
and he liked do you guys try mine do you
remember I made it last Thanksgiving
it doesn't seem to be last Thanksgiving
um I cooked all day while I was seven
months pregnant in my kitchen while you
guys sat on the couch and watched
football at your house at my apartment
I have no memory of being at your house
wait like
during the day
and I was cooking I made mac and cheese
it wasn't like really pregnant nobody
helped me it wasn't an adverbal if
that's what I remember it wasn't and I
remember looking at me like we'll do it
together like it was just mac and cheese
and
um turkey no and
the spinach artichoke dip because then
like we went to Mom's and there was a
feast but like I just wanted to
contribute my spinach artichoke dip you
didn't eat at your house no no but we we
watched some football
you really don't remember none of this
sounds even remotely familiar to me and
Kayla was staying with me well and
Olivia and Zach too oh that sort of
really a lot of Frozen well I didn't eat
the spinach artichoke dip okay and if I
did I certainly don't remember it
that's that's good
you know because if it was really bad
horrible yeah you would have never said
you would never stop talking right no
you're right
um so maybe I'll make that but like
mashing all those artichokes it's a lot
of work it's a lot of work so drop in
the comments what are you making for the
Super Bowl Claudia sent me some like
Tick Tock [__] Jackie hated my idea
Tick Tock [__] Tick Tick boom yeah
we bring in the noise now you know that
song right yeah
I still don't know I played it for you
the other day so that doesn't mean I
know it you said you liked it
speaking of things I like
today's episode before we continue ad
break is brought to you by Honey Love
ladies we all have that one bra we wear
on the daily it's the one I'm wearing
now and I've been wearing it since I got
here because it's the most comfortable
one we own and let me tell you that bra
you thought was nice doesn't compare to
our new favorite one I'm talking about
it from our sponsor honey love they have
revolutionized the bra game so you no
longer have to deal with uncomfortable
underwire without sacrificing support
you'll immediately feel and see the
difference their bras are so comfortable
you won't want to take it off for a
limited time only you can get honey love
on sale you can get 20 off your entire
order with the code toast at
honeylove.com support our show check out
honey love and use code toast so I've
been wearing the bra from honey love
like literally for now 10 days straight
I did wash it a couple times but you
know I don't really need to switch it up
I found the perfect bra
um with honey love you'll never
experience the feeling of like needing
to take your bra off after a long day
their bras are so comfortable you will
forget that you're wearing them you may
even sleep in them I can attest to the
truth of that statement their best
seller crossover bra is so comfortable
it is be sure to be your new go-to this
bra gives all the support of traditional
bras without using any of the underwires
plus mesh detailing adds a little touch
of sexiness it is the bra that you'll
actually enjoy wearing and you won't
want to take off if you're tired of bras
that cause bulging in your back honey
loves bras are designed with the back
smoothing fabric to prevent the bra
bulge so I had never worn a bra from
Honey Love
maybe before like maybe two months ago
but I had so many other um like from
their shapewear lines I had so many
other products and I knew without even
like trying it on that this would be
it's a company I trust and I knew that
the bras would be good and I was 100
right they have you covered for everyday
looks workouts weddings and more treat
yourself to the best shapewear on the
market and save 20 off at honeylove.com
with code toast that's code toast at
honeylove.com cinched snatched and
lifted it's hot girl season thanks to
Honey Love
it's always hot girl season when you're
30. oh ain't that the trip
our next story some Royal news because
why not for the thousands episode 100
it's only fair King Charles wants Prince
Harry back in the family and at the car
Nation says a source uh says a source
who's dumb or lying says a source who
must be practically deranged yeah
there's no way I feel like of all of
them Charles hates what Harry the most
okay but I've been seeing this kind of
theme like a couple times that like
Charles wants him back and then I was
reading what the source says is the
reason why and like it's not the worst
reason
um but the king of the Carnation of King
Charles Cavalier Spaniel III is less
than 100 days away he'll be carnated on
May 6th the birthday of the snatchler so
he'll be birthed as a king and Santa
will be rebirthed as a 2010
five-year-old 26 year old 26 26 version
though the royal family has made no
statement following the release of
Harry's bombshell Memoir spare a source
close to the Royal household tells
people in this week's cover story so
like
salt sprinkling grains of salt
everywhere that the new British monarch
wants his younger son to attend his
ceremony in Westminster Abbey quote it
is such a momentous occasion for Charles
and he would want his son to be at the
car Nation to witness it he would like
to have Harry back in the family if they
don't sort it out it would always be
part of the king's Reign and how he has
left his family disjointed that's true
he has had a reputation as a distant
parent and it would be awful for him for
that to continue
a royal historian told people that quite
apart from Charles's paternal hope to
reunite with his son one of the jobs of
the royal family is showing how to cope
with the problems we all have in a human
and thoughtful way what will be a
success for the family in the future is
not reconciliation necessarily but
Mutual acceptance of different ideas and
priorities so they're saying like it's
such a good example for this country if
he's able to bring his son back into the
fold no because think about Lizzy even
though
um Megan and Harry like left during her
Reign they still they only really
started acting crazy once she passed
like they had still had that tie to her
and they still had enormous respect for
her
um and they don't have that for Charles
if anything they have like a bigger
disdain than anyone else so I do I do
understand this line of thinking that
like it really reflects poorly on him
and he's supposed to be like setting
example for people I understand this
line of thinking um though if anyone's
asking me like I just completely
disagree I I feel like most people
most people who are watching and you
know families who are feeling like
related to this like would see what
Harry did and like would not relate to
forgiving him an acting and like letting
him into big family moments again like
well I by the way I think it it's
whatever side you take if you take Harry
and Megan's side you support them
cutting off their family like cutting
out toxic people both sides want them to
have nothing to do with each other right
it's like it's called like having
boundaries and like eventually like
realizing even if it's someone you love
and it's your family like sometimes the
best thing is like to go no contact and
like really not so I think that also
sets a good example yeah you know yeah
and I just I I don't know I don't think
I agree with this line of thinking I
don't think that that's what it would
achieve to have them there and by the
way if they even had them there because
this uh person also said there have been
some very grave disagreements between
them but the Platinum Jubilee and the
funerals of the queen and Prince Philip
did demonstrate that they could put
personal enmity aside for the sake of
the bigger cause and that is what the
Carnation will be about
yes but like what's happened in the last
six months like is beyond the pale you
know it's is that was all before the
documentary of the book BD and B B Yeah
a hundred percent and by the way when
Harry and Megan did show up for the
certain things I mean it became all
about them I mean how could it not it
was so crazy and also they were like
they left the Jubilee early because they
like didn't like how they were treated
um it's never been smooth sailing and
like to have to have like William and
Kate like sit next to them or even like
be like it's just who are you fool like
you're not a pack of liars true it's
true real than a pack of liars you're
not fooling us I I actually think it
would be better if they just stay away
like better for them and everyone better
for Harry and Megan to protect their
piece and better for the family to not
like be doormat yeah no honestly there's
no way that one the coronation of
Charles wouldn't then just become about
Harry and Megan because that's just the
situation we're in and I'm sure Charles
doesn't want that and and Charles like
does not seem like this like I'll take
the high right highest like yeah he
seems like like kind of a thirsty King
not thirsty but like I feel like
throughout his life he's been very
selfish no
tough like as a dad and especially
towards Harry how he talks about that in
his book and this wouldn't be the time
where he's gonna like soften yeah when
they just took a big hot dump on him
yeah they should not go to the Carnation
I don't know if People magazine is like
you know the most legitimate Source I
don't know if they're thinking about her
like trying to get Harry and Megan to
come I don't think that they should I
don't think that they should but I had
seen like a couple headlines that were
like the king wants him at the Carnation
so I'm like
I saw a headline that said it's
Carnation Day
the window is open so is that door I
didn't know they did that anymore who
knew we had 8 000 salad plates I didn't
know that no yeah that's kind of crazy I
know that's the headline that's like
excess yeah thing it's excess well
that's giving privilege it's giving one
percent it's giving like you know show
your privilege
are you ready for our fifth and final
story of our 1000th episode the finals
[Music]
it's for the better for everyone
gorgeous
they nailed it
real story is a little Super Bowl news a
little commercial dropping I love this
Jennifer Coolidge continues her it girl
era no I literally sent you a story
yesterday about Frida you did I texted
you as I was sitting next to you on the
couch about their Kelsey not Kelsey
Kelly Kelsey
Jason Kelsey's wife oh yes you did okay
wait how about
it's a two-pronged okay
um so go with your first one let's start
with yours no go with your first one
it's already pulled up and I'll pull up
the second one okay airdrop it to me I
will Jennifer Coolidge continues her it
girl ERA with new Elf Cosmetics Super
Bowl commercial
oh Elf Cosmetics Elf Cosmetics have just
tapped Jennifer Coolidge for their Super
Bowl commercial and she's living out her
dream of playing a dolphin this comes
after a streak of wins for the White
Lotus star and now the actress can add
Super Bowl commercial star to the
pantheon projects that she's worked on
this year I could have guessed somebody
would tap her that's just smart
marketing she's burying the culture very
in the Zeitgeist and we'd love to see it
yeah I'm not all for this like releasing
of commercials early like could we be
surprised I know yes but like I do feel
like sometimes the commercial slip
through the cracks and like but then
after there's like a Roundup like they
exist online like it's like a lot of
people before I became like a big
football fan like just tune in for the
commercials like can we can we release
something like to the imagination so
true I mean not all of them have dropped
and it would have been cool to see this
like live and not have the spoiler right
spoiled but I love this for Jen this era
that we're in and elf is like really
kind of I'm happy for them that they
have that much money for a Super Bowl
commercial because they're really if
you're like in the beauty like tick tock
talk like things like viral Trends they
really consistently kill it for for like
a dollar you need good makeup and you
have a dollar go to else you'll get a
full face of makeup yeah I slept space
and she is promoting their viral power
grip primer I use it which is fitting
because she's in her prime oh cute I
like that yeah so Part B of this story
is that Jason Kelsey's pregnant wife
Kylie has been featured in a full page
ad wishing her luck ahead of the Super
Bowl Kylie Kelsey is being honored for
her big contribution to the big game
it's not every year that your husband's
team ends up in the Super Bowl
especially when you were expecting a
baby any day soon to be mom of three
began making headlines earlier this week
when her husband revealed that she's 38
weeks pregnant that she's bringing her
OB GYN to the game as fans wonder
whether the Kelsey bull will feature the
birth of the third Kelsey girl Frida
decided to sponsor Kelsey as their MVP
quote most valuable Pusher they the
brand Freedom mom which isn't me and
they also free the baby it's like the
best brand yeah you use the no sucker
thing right oh I use the everything but
like also for postpartum stuff like all
of the things that you don't know what
they are until you need them right um
just get the freedom on stuff it comes
in a bundle and it's like everything
that you know and I got it like before I
gave birth I was like what are these
things yeah you did every single one of
them every single one I and I re-up they
have the best um disposable underwear
for afterwards I feel like that's
actually a really good gift to get
someone like who you know who is about
to give birth like that's a very
thoughtful gift yeah and then for baby
stuff like our thermometer rail file or
like everything is Frida so it's totally
on brand
they published an ad saying this Sunday
will generate over 500 million dollars
of ads and sponsorships around football
players but the real MVP isn't going to
be on the field today we announced in
Philadelphia Inquirer our official
sponsorship of Kylie Kelsey in the spot
of motherhood in the sport of motherhood
so cute well Jason is sweating it out
with the Eagles on the field she'll be
38 weeks pregnant in the stands with her
OB GYN as her plus one so as he pushes
that football through his legs she could
be pushing something twice as big
through hers no like love this great
facts I know love this love this like
and they said and that's what deserves a
sponsorship I agree like we're just out
here giving birth for free
literally with no awards no awards no
sponsorships I love this I also feel
like they could have included Mama
Kelsey
yeah like this but no they're like the
go-to
um for like pregnancy perinatal Brands
so like this is absolutely perfect but I
also feel like someone should have given
her a commercial she was on their
podcast because they asked because
there's a petition going around to have
Mama Kelsey do the coin toss yeah she's
really the only one who could be
impartial 100
um and so they said like Mom like would
you do the coin toss and she was like no
there are so many more accomplished
people who should do it and they were
like what like you're knocking moms like
don't take away from like and I feel
like she like we need to be lifting them
up she thinks she didn't she hasn't
contributed to like football please like
you raised two big football stars right
you fed them which it was not easy you
drove into practice yes no so did you
smelled their farts so true you wash
your smelly like Josh yeah
I feel like she needs a commercial I
will be surprised if there's not one
like maybe we don't know about it yet
because someone wants to keep something
under wraps yeah but I would be very
surprised if there's not a single
commercial that doesn't like reference
her or have her I will be surprised
turnaround they would only have had two
weeks to come up with it and I feel like
a lot of Super Bowl commercials are
tight turn around because they always
want to be like really relevant yeah and
also like the Jennifer Coolidge one
references the joke she made about not a
joke about wanting to play a dolphin in
her next role which was like somewhat
recently which was at the Golden Globes
uh so it's possible and even if a bran
won't do something like the NFL like me
show you something I know if someone
doesn't like we ride it on yeah
yeah and then if someone doesn't like I
can't say I'll be watching the Super
Bowl again if you guys use this
opportunity I agree unless it's like the
49ers versus the 49ers
um or the Cowboys so that is our
thousandth episode
it felt very thousandy you know there
were a lot of elements about it that
were so thousand
I think pretty much what I would say is
I think the whole time we kind of kept
it we kept it one thousandth you best
believe it we kept in it we kept it one
thousand
that was Harmony that was Harmony and I
love that we ended our 1000 episode with
Harmony
we have moments of acrimony moments
which is always so fun you know because
you did bring up mixing yesterday for no
[__] reason oh my God
overall this show is 99 Harmony one
percent acrimony and the acrimony makes
for Great Clips on social media 100
so that is our show again thank you to
everyone who made it possible for us to
get to 1 000 episodes thank you guys so
much for tuning in day in and day out we
love being a part of your day we love
doing the totes the toast will literally
be going on till the day we die love you
thank you so much for listening to the
toast the millennial Morning Show where
we deliver the past five stories that
you need to know every Monday through
Friday on YouTube so if you're watching
this on YouTube please don't forget to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast moved on Spotify iTunes
it's your public video I already kiss
box all the places
stunning and
get lit challenge did we are
love you bye we're keeping it we keeping
it one thousand